we're given two matrices over here
matrix e and matrix d and they ask us
what is e d which is another way of
saying what is the product of matrix e
and matrix d so just so i remember what
i'm doing let me copy and paste this and
then i'm going to get out my
and then i'm going to get out my little
scratch pad so let me paste that over
here
so we have all the information we needed
and so let's try to work this out so
matrix e times matrix d so this is
matrix e
times matrix
matrix d which is equal to matrix e is
all of this business
so it is 0
3 5
5 5 2
times matrix d
which is all of this so we're going to
multiply it times
3
3 4
4
negative 2
negative 2.
now the first thing that we have to
check is whether this is even a valid
operation now the matrix multiplication
is a human-defined operation that just
happens in fact all operations are that
happen to have neat properties now the
way that us humans have defined matrix
multiplication it only works if when
we're multiplying our two matrices so
this right over here has two rows and
three columns so it's a two by three
matrix and this has three rows and two
columns it's three by two this only
works we can only multiply this matrix
times this matrix if the number of
columns on this matrix is equal to the
number of rows on this matrix and in
this situation it is so i can actually
multiply them if these two numbers
weren't equal if the number of columns
here we're not equal to the number of
rows here then this would not be a a
valid operation at least the way that we
have defined matrix multiplication the
other thing you always have to remember
is that e times d is not always the same
thing as d times e order matters when
you're multiplying matrices it doesn't
matter if you're multiplying regular
numbers but it matters for matrices but
let's actually work this out so we're
going to get
what we're going to get is actually
going to be a 2
by 2 matrix but i'm going to create some
space here because we're going to do
some computation so this is going to be
equal to
this is going to be equal to i'm going
to make a huge 2x2 matrix here
so the way we get the top left entry the
top left entry is essentially going to
be
it's going to be
this row it's going to be this row
times this product
if you view them each as vectors and you
have some familiar with the dot product
we're essentially going to take the dot
product of that and that if you have no
idea what that is i'm about to show you
this entry is going to be 0 times 3 so 0
times 3 plus 3 times 3
plus 3 times 3
plus 5 times 4 plus 5 times four so that
is the top left entry and i already see
that i'm going to run out of space here
so let me move this over
so let me move this over to the right
some space so i have some breathing room
now we can do
the top right entry this was the top
left now we're going to do the top right
so the top right entry
is going to be
is going to be this row
this row times this column
this row times this column notice the
entry is getting the row from the first
matrix and the column from the second
one that's kind of determining its
position so once again it's going to be
0 times 4
0 times 4 plus 3 times negative 2
three times negative two
plus five times negative two five times
negative two
and we keep going
the bottom left entry is going to be
this row the second row here times the
first column here
so it's 5 times 3 so 5 times 3
plus 5 times 3 plus 5 times
3
plus 2 times 4
plus 2 times 4 and we're almost done we
just need to multiply or take the dot
product of this row with this column
right over here so it's going to be 5
times 4
5 times 4
plus
5 times negative 2. plus 2 times
negative 2 2 times negative 2.
and so this is going to be equal to and
we can just evaluate this now
let's see
0 times 3 is 0 this is 9
plus 20 is this is 29 this this all
simplified to 29
all of this this is 0 this is negative 6
and then this is minus 10. so this all
simplifies to negative 16
negative 16
this right over here it's 15 plus 15
which is 30
plus 8 so this is 38
38 and then finally this is 20
20
minus 10
minus 4. so this is going to be
6.
so this is all going to simplify to 6.
so this all became 29 negative 16 38 and
6.
29 negative 16 38 and 6.
so 29
29
negative 16
38
and 6. let's check our answer
and we got it right